サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
よろしくお願いします
本当に雨の中で厳しい条件なのに来ていただきましてありがとうございます
あまり心配することはない
人間というのは 何て言いますか
防水加工されていますからね
みんななんで雨が嫌がるのかわからない
濡れたってどうったことはないんだけどね
はい それから今日の話を始まります
で 悪と向き合うというね
えーと 私と世界の幸福論
まず善悪の勉強から始め始めます
あの悪と向き合いたいんだけど
悪って何かとわからなかったらね
で 世界は悪に満ちているなどのセットフレーズをやめて
新たに善悪について理解するべきですね
まあみんなよく言ってる
世の中汚れている あれやこれやとかね
こんなみんな言ってることに乗るんじゃなくてね
実際 善とは何 悪とは何ということはね
ちゃんと理性で理解した方がよろしいんですね
順番なんですけど 何か悪が先に喋っちゃいますけど
仏教ではいっぱいクサラクサル
プンヤパーパという善悪というふうな流れなんですけどね
じゃあまあ早速説明の中に入りましょう
はい 悪は 2種類 善は 2種類
まとめて 4種類になるんです
これ パーリ語というのは
ものすごくこの仏教が勝てるための言語みたいなもんでね
なかなか他の言語にはぴったし訳できないんですね
1 はプンヤ で まあ普通日本語にすれば功徳
良い行いということなんですね
プンヤのこの語感で定義しているところがありまして
この何か心の中で何か気持ちいい喜びが感じる行為
行為といったら体で行為
言葉でしゃべることも行為
考えることも行為 それでやっていると
なんとなく何か心が喜びを感じる
これはあのポジティブ的な喜びなんですね
ネガティブ的な人間が喜んだりするんだけどね
それはプンヤというんですね
2番目 クサラ クサラはなかなか訳できないんですね
で 私は一応考えて 善 道あるいは巧みという言葉を考えたんだけどね
アビリティという英語でも使えますね
アビリティ使っちゃうと能力になるんですね
英語でも一応エクスペリエンス
プルーデンス エフィシエンシー
これも 善なんですよ 善悪の善はそういう 2種類あるんです
というわけで 能力はね
善なんです よく理解してください
結構仏教の定義というのは精密ですからね
世間の考えでこれから理解しないでください
そこでも反対は簡単です
パープ それは悪 罪というものなんですね
4番目 アクサラ クサラの反対
アクサラ これはまあ不善
不動ということですね
要するに 2番目の反対の意味で理解すればいいんですね
プルーデンスは全くないし
エクスペリエンスというね
あのもうというのは何でしたっけね
方便ですかね エフィシエンシーっていうのはもうすごいアクティブというね
活発ということ それもなくてね
まあ普通日本語で言えば下手ということなんですね
何でも下手くそという感じ
能力ない 能力ないことも悪なんですね
そういうことで  4 種類があると理解しましょう
はい さらに説明していきます
ん？あ 間違えた また入ってる
2 回 はい 善と不善 悪と不善ですね
じゃあまずは悪と不善の説明で始まりましょうか
悪とはそこにいう罪です
諸宗教と社会が多種類の罪について語るが
そのリストから普遍的なリストを作れます
世間ではそこを あの 何といいますか
同意したものはないんですね
みんなこれが罪 これが罪と勝手に言っているだけ
だから それぞれそれぞれの宗教が自分たちの罪のリストがあって
だから宗教間でも合わない場合があるんですね
それから文化的にもね
日本人には罪があって
ヨーロッパ人にはヨーロッパ人が考える罪があって
中国人には中国人が考える罪があるんですね
これは合わない場合もあるんですね
そこで その全部リストから普遍的なリストを作っちゃえば
誰にでも共通するリスト
だから独特のリストは使わない
例えば 神を信じている人々は
神を信じないことが重罪であるという
しかし 世の中でみんな神を信じているわけじゃないんだからね
だからリストからそれは削除できます
で 殺してはならないということは
何か考えてみれば 誰でも認めるわけにはいきませんね
宗教があろうがなかろうが
殺しは良くないと しかし
宗教によってどんな程度の殺しが良くないかということはあるんだけど
そこは我々は削除する
例えば日本の政府であろうが
どんな国での政府であろうか
殺人は禁止 しかし 政府は人々に言って殺して指令するんですね
戦争なんか起こしたりして
殺してもいいと 日本では平和な国だから問題ないんだけど
警察はいつでもピストルを持っているんだから
あれ 何のために？たまたま上へ上げたり取ったりして遊ぶためじゃないでしょう
国民を殺すためなんです
だから殺す 殺される条件が国民満たしてないんだから大丈夫なんです
そういうことで 政府が殺人犯罪やと言いながら
政府指令で軍隊を動かして結構人を殺せ殺しちゃうんですよ
アメリカも結構やってる
人権侵害と他人の故意に言う割には
ものの見事に人権侵害するし
戦争犯罪と他人の故意に言うなら
言う割に自分たちで堂々と犯しているし
それは合法でそうですね
まあそういうことで そういうわけで
このそこは我々は削除して殺してはならないということは普遍的だから
それを取るというふうに
私たちにもこの悪のリストは作られます
この仏教が言う悪のリストは偏ってはならない
信仰に偏ってはならない
時代に偏ってはならない
文化に偏ってはならない
普遍的なもの 共通するものでなければいけません
でなきゃ 理性的で客観的
科学的にならないんですね
だから 悪の場合は なんか我々にとっては悪のリストが欲しいんです
例えば 嫉妬してはいけないというね
嫉妬することが罪なんですね
いくらなんでもどんな人間もそう思っちゃうでしょ
嫉妬はちょっとまずいとかね
そういうふうに この 共通する普遍的なリストを作られます
では定義 仏教の定義 自分と他人の生命に対する迷惑行為ですよ
結局は しかし 明らかにしてほしい
この仏教 自分と他人なんです
自分に対する迷惑行為も自分でやってますけど
罪です だから他人をいじめることは罪でしょ
自分で自分をいじめること
罪です 例えば神様を信じている宗教では
自殺は重罪と言っているんですね
意味がわからない なんでやと
だって魂は死にませんから
肉体は減らっちゃって
自殺したってもいいんじゃなくて
意味がわからない 自殺はダメダメと言うんだけど
言うだけで聖書には書いてない
自殺禁止という それでは仏教的に見ると
自分に害を与えることも罪です
重罪とは言いませんだけどね
しかし 自分に害を与えると言ったところで一概に解説できません
例えば 心はすごく清らかな人がいる
体はもう重病で末期で
一日でも生きることが自分にとっては耐え難い苦しみで
それから看病する人々にとっては大変迷惑で
だからなんで 1 日生きるんですかね
だからその人は人々のことを慈しんで
あの この人々にはまあどうせ私はそろそろ死ぬしね
なんで迷惑かけるのかとか言って
自分で命を絶っても それは罪じゃないんですね
結局は だから そういう条件によってね
でも世の中の自殺はそうじゃなくてね
怒りで憎しみでやっていることだから
それは罪になるんですね
だから 悪の定義は 自分と他人に迷惑をかける行為
お釈迦様が出さ悪それ重不善というリストを解かれ解かれているのですが
単語は罪ではなく不善になっているんですね
だから我々にとっては
こんな世の中のこと 全部勉強できるわけじゃないしね
だからリスト作れませんよと思ったっても
仏教ではリスト作ってあるんです
この仏教のリストはどちらにも偏ってない真理に基づいたリストなんです
だからそれは誰にも変えることはできません
だいたい一般的に大乗仏教
我々の初期仏教 誰でも使っているこの十善十悪という二重のリストがあるんです
それは一定しています
しかし その中にすべて入っていますから
結構難しい だからお釈迦様がパーパということではなく
アクセラという言葉を使ってはいるんです
罪とは人類が皆否定する悪行為です
だから罪と定義する場合は
人類皆否定する悪行為は罪になるんですね
これは罪 かなり怖いものなんです
はい 今度はあの悪シラの定義
パーパの定義はありました
だって悪は二種類ですからね
判断能力が乏しい 判断が間違っている
あるいは愚かな行為 成長を妨げる行為
理解能力に障害を与える行為
そうすると幅が広くなるんですね
悪スラの場合は パーパの場合は幅が狭いんです
我々は悪やと気にしないで結構やっていることいっぱいあるでしょう
判断能力間違い 判断間違っちゃうわ
成長を妨げることをやっているわ
やっているのに宗教家があんた何やって？これで戒律に一人いないんだよと
私がやっていることはとかね
だからやってもいいやとかね
というふうに弁解までする
あの 日本では これはお坊さんたちが作った冗談の話かどうかはわかりませんだけど
日本のお坊さんたちは酒飲んでるんだからね
本当は飲酒禁止なんですけど
だからまあ酒の名前変えようと
般若党と 般若っての智慧だからね
それでいいやというふうに
まあ結局判断能力が乏しくなる行為なんですね
これはいくらなんでもやってはいけない
例えば酒飲んだからって罪じゃないんですよ
嘘を言ってるわけじゃないし
酒飲んで嘘を言ってるのは別話
別な話で 酒飲んでから嘘をつくんだから
酒は罪ということはないんです
酒飲むことは悪スラなんです
パーパではないんです
わかりやすく言えば パーパを起こしちゃうと人殺したり
あるいは強盗やったりとかね
地獄に落ちる でも酒飲んで地獄に落ちるってことはちょっと言いづらいんです
酒飲んで酔ってやったことは別
酔っ払って人をぶん殴ったら
それが罪ですね やったことが不善です
だから不善をやっているからといって
直行地獄に行くとかとはあまり言わないんです
ただまあ別にあまり悪いことということなんですね
釈尊が 10種類のリストは
悪と不善両方をまとめています
だからこの十 十 十悪の
リストがありますね そちらでは悪も入っていて
不善も入っている だから十悪と言わないで十不善と言っているんです
あの十のリストの中で酒飲んではいけませんと入ってないんです
リストは言うならば殺生
中盗むこと 不邪淫 邪淫ですか
不邪淫ですかね 邪淫 それで嘘をつくこと
で 粗悪語する人を怒鳴ったり侮辱したりすることをね
それから噂を言うこと
それから無駄話 それから異常な怒り
異常な欲と邪見 酒は入ってないんです
罪を犯すと国不幸に陥る
罪を犯しちゃうと 他の生命にも害を与える迷惑行為です
不善行為をすると生命は退化してしまいます
だから地獄に落ちると言わない
あんた退化するんだよと
退化の結果 地獄に落ちるかもしれませんだけどね
だからこの差を理解しておきましょう
そうすると皆様も立派な理性のある人間になります
違いは微妙に見えるが
そうではありません 違いは微妙じゃないかなと
微妙ではないんです 不幸に陥る行為と退化する行為っていうのは同じじゃないんです
仲間ですけどね はい ちょっとこれ
これで理解できると思います
で 悪不善功徳善の関係
これで左側 このアクサラということありますね
アクサラは大きいんですね
このアクサラの不善の中に悪罪があるんです
ということは 罪は罪でもありながら不善でもあります
不善はすべて罪になるわけじゃないんです
アクサラすべてはパーパにならない
パーパはすべてアクサラなんです
そこで善の方が 功徳 行為は善行為ですけど
善行為は功徳 行為よりもたくさんあります
はい まあ今日は悪だけ説明したかったんだからね
申し訳ないんだけど あの
定義していないね 書いてないと思います
だから普通に言います
例えば善行為って何なのかと
善 右側のこのまあ格好いい丸
こっちはギザギザでね
悪行為だからね そういうイラストにしたんです
こちらは結構格好よくいい丸なんですね
で クサラっていうのは善行為
善行為とはあちらの反対ですよ
自分が向上する行為 巧みな行為
で 理性で行う行為 人格向上するもの
例えば勉強する 道徳は勉強するとかね
これ善行為なんです あるいはしっかりと技術を学んで
人々に役に立つような技術になる
善行為です なぜ自分も成長するし
人々も助かっているんだから
だから自分の技術能力を毎日毎日磨いてみる
それも善行為です 家の奥さんがいろいろ本を持ってきて料理の勉強をする
もっと健康にいいものを家族に食べさせたいと
いろいろバラエティを作ってあげたいんだと
だから自分の責任だからね
料理作ってあげること
それはもうしっかりやりますということで
自分も成長する それ善行為です
善行為はものすごいたくさんあります
それで功徳っていうのは特別な行為なんですね
困っている人を助けてあげる
殺されて殺されるようになっている命を救ってあげる
例えばどこかのね あの
チキンファームありますね
そこでみんな殺されますからね
そこでお願いしますから
鶏一羽いただけませんかと
金払いますよと 倍金払ってでも鶏一羽連れてきて育ててあげる
死ぬまで殺せない だから殺される運命の命一つ助けたんですね
ボランティアをやるとかね
災害の時行ってとことん協力してあげるとかね
そういうのは善行でありながら功徳行為でもあります
功徳だけに集中すると
もしかするともう足が引っかかる可能性もあります
善行にはそれがないんです
だから功徳をする人は
やっぱりこれ善になるようにしなくちゃいけないんです
例えばボランティアやるやる
やってもやってももうやりきれなくなっちゃって
腹が立つとかね そうしちゃうと
もう不正になってるんですね
自分がある年月は善行したのに
まあ嫌になっちゃったと
で ストップする可能性もあります
自分の功徳行為が同時に善行為にもなるならば
その問題は起きません
次 完成について考えましょう
やっぱり何でも完成しなくちゃいけないでしょうね
悪は激しく 不善は徐々に命を破壊します
よく繰り返してください
悪は激しく命を破壊する
例えば人を殺しちゃったら
もう自分の寿命もそれで終わりですね
あるいは隠れている たった意味がないんです
毎日自分を悪行為が破壊していくんです
だから悪は 罪は激しく
命を破壊する 不善は徐々に
破壊します 要するに判断を間違ったり
失敗したり もう下手くそで何やっても下手で
結果がダメで そうなってくると
じわじわじわと自分の
人格が下がっていくんですね
心が みんなを知っていると
結構失敗しちゃうと落ち込んじゃうでしょ
失敗したからで死ぬわけないでしょ
でも落ち込むんですよ
落ち込んだらさらに能力が
低下するんです 完成する以前
人は死んで不幸に陥ります
ですから この罪と不善行為は完成できません
完成する前にやられているんです
完成する前に地獄に落ちているんです
例えば殺人 考えてください
殺人を完成するためにどうすればいい？地球上のすべての人間を殺さなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分だけ残して ありえないでしょ
盗みを完成するならば
他人持っているものを全部盗まなくちゃかんです
できる？できない だから不善と悪には完成がないんです
まあ不善というのは未完成の意味ですからね
未完成に完成ないんですからね
で 完成が現実的に成り立たない
始めたらもう自分自身が壊れているんです
人を殺したっても 一人二人で終わりです
それからからくるして
テロリストみたいに ISIS みたいに組織的に殺すんですけど
こんなの長持ちはしません
完成はない 功徳にも完成はありません
さらにできるやつです
それで功徳行為 いわゆる人を助けてあげる
ボランティアする お布施をする
戒律を守ってみるとか
自分が精一杯やってももっとできるでしょうと
では困っている人を助ける
何人助けられる？だから功徳も完成できません
だからお釈迦様が菩薩の時はね
なんで功徳完成しなくちゃとかね
そこでこのパーラミタという波羅蜜
無始なるものすごい長い間でね
過去からやってきたんですよ
だから完成できなかったからなんです
一回やって またやって
またやって 何千万回も生まれ変わってやって
やって そこを積み重ねてやっと完成になる
それでやっていると 菩薩の心の中で善というものが入ってくるんです
功徳ではなくて 善 プンヤではなく
善がやらなく善をやらなくちゃあかんと
そこで善になってくると完成になるんですね
完成になってブッダになるんです
だからこの人を助けることを完成したければ
人に解脱に達する道を教えてくださいなんです
だから善行為の中でトップになってますよ
道を教えることが なぜならば
助けられた人がもう完全に助かっているんです
悩み苦しみはもう消えるんです
寿命を終えて幸福になります
だから功徳を積んでいる人は
寿命ありかけり いろいろやります
だからその人には寿命を終えることができます
罪を犯す人には寿命が終わるまでは生きられません
不善やる人にも寿命が終わるまではいられません
自分の業が与えられた寿命より先に死ぬんです
功徳を行う人 善を行う人が
自分に与えられた寿命は完璧に完了するんです
だから生まれた時が時
業があなたの寿命は 100年やと言ったならば
ちょうど 100年で その日で
その時間で亡くなるんです 100
年と 6ヶ月と 2週間と 13時間よと寿命を決めたならば
ぴったしで 13時間過ぎるとぱっと亡くなるんです
だから功徳をやることのいいことそれなんです
自分の寿命が全うできるんですね
寿命が全うできるとは
突然病気になったり 寿命が縮めることはないということなんです
突然がんが発生しちゃって
もう見つかることは手遅れでということはないんですね
そこで 功徳を積む人にとって完成はできませんだけど
寿命が終わるまで完成できません
寿命が終わったら幸福なところに当然生まれ変わるんです
ものすごい幸福なところに
善は完成できます これ勉強してください
善は完成できます 完成とは智慧が現れて解脱に達することです
だから人格向上だから
理性能力の開発だから
正しい判断能力を身につくことだから
正しい観察能力を身につけて正しい行為をすることだから
そういう智慧が現れていくんです
だから 功徳ではなく 善を行うと智慧が現れます
功徳だけだったら功徳で終わるんです
智慧がないんです 仏典でそれははっきりするんです
いっぱい徳が積んでいる人だけど
智慧がないんだと 世の中でいくらでもいますよ
良いことをするはするは
もう我々にはかなわないぐらい良いことをする人々がいるんです
しかし 智慧が現れてこない
私は今思い出したのはマザーテレサさんなんですね
もうかなわないね あの彼女がやった善行為は
我々みたいな人間には
しかし あれは功徳行為なんですね
智慧が現れない しかし
彼女はいっぱい功徳を積んだんだから
功徳の方で彼女にちょっと彼女をいじってあげるんです
ちょっと智慧を開発しなさいと
これだけではやりきれんやと
インドのね 貧しい死にかけている人々の面倒というのは
いくら見たってもやりきれんでしょうに
やればやるほど人間が不幸であることを発見するだけで
だから彼女が最後になってくると
なんだこりゃと なんだこりゃと
神が作った世界だったらね
こんなに不幸だけに満ちてるはずがないよと
だから彼女にちょっと最後になってくると
善も心に 何か心が法則的に言うんですよ
これだけではあなたには人生納得できんやと
だから もし彼女が 生命は誰だって苦しんで生まれて
苦しんで生きていて 苦しんで死ぬんだということを理解してならば落ち着くんです
それはどこまでかとわからないんだけどね
しかし 彼女はすごい立派な方であることは明らかなんですね
前提なものごとを理解して
理解して 判断能力を正していくんです
それで何か理解したということは
智慧が現れたことでしょう
それで智慧が完成したら終わり
すべてということで いくら功徳を積んでも
私はスリランカ人に言う言葉なんです
いくら功徳を積んでも
お寺の面倒を見たり お坊さんにお布施したり
まあもう月に毎月もういろんな法要に参加したり
スリランカ人は結構やるんですよ
いろんな聖地に行ったりして
派手なお祭りやったりとかね
忙しいみんな 私が言うのは
あんた方いくらやってもね
毎日法要とか法事やってもね
悟りませんよと いくら功徳積んでも覚えておきなさいと
悟りたければクサラをやってくださいと
で みんなへーということで悟りたくないでしょうね
善を完成すると ついでに功徳も完成します
面白いんですよ 善を完成すると
功徳も自動的に完成しているんです
だって功徳は善の中にあるんだから
はい 功徳から善への進み方
はい 今日で皆様にちょっとした勉強するところがあります
この功徳っていうのはみんな知ってるんです
私が教えなくても 例えば教会に行っても
ミサ終わると何か持ってきますね
みんなお盆をね そちらでみんな寄付しますよ
あれはだいたい教会の維持管理だけではなく
いろんなボランティア活動に使ったりはする
あるいは言葉を変えて
貧しい人々を助けるために
目が見えない人々を助けるために
何とか何とか この施設を維持管理するために寄付してください
寄付してくださいとかね
日本の仏教徒も時々募金活動をいろいろやっているでしょうね
ああいうのは功徳行為なんですね
でもこれってやりきれないでしょ
いくらやっても だから功徳を善になるようにしなくちゃいけないんです
要するに パーリ語で言えば
プンニャをクサラに変えなくちゃいけない
パーリ語だったらよくわかりますよ
日本語で言っちゃうと
なんかあんまり差がないんですね
プンニャー功徳をクサラ善にプンニャクサラに変えなくちゃいけない
この変える方 変える方法
これから説明します 一つの例だけで
だって功徳たくさんありますよ
功徳の種類たくさんあります
一つの例 不殺生 生命を殺さないということは功徳です
パーリ語だったらパーナーティパーターヤヴェーラマニになるんですね
殺す意があっても 殺さなくてはいけない条件に遭遇しても
殺生を止めることは功徳行為です
殺したいんだけど 殺さない
この場合は殺さなきゃあかん
でも殺さない 頑張っちゃう
それは功徳行為なんです
徐々に理性を駆使して命の意義を理解する
それで殺さないだけじゃない
この人はもうちょっと宿題やるんです
殺すということで命を奪うことでしょう
命って何なのかと 理解勉強しようとするんです
生きる権利が皆にあることを理解する
そうすると 誰だって生きていきたい
死にたくないんですね
だから生きる権利 アリからゾウまでみんなにあるんだと
すべての生命にあるんだと
微生物からクジラまで
ああ これみんなの権利だと
尊厳だと 尊厳を守ること
素晴らしいだと 私は権利を守っているんだと
だからお前を殺さない程度はもう飛んじゃったんですね
みんな魚釣ってるんだからね
やっぱりしょうがない
誰でもやってるんだから
じゃあ私も釣りまと これなくなっちゃったんです
命の尊厳 生きる権利守ってあげると
いきなり不殺生のレベルがガクンと上がったんです
そこで不殺生の場合はストレス溜まるんですよ
友達がね 今度ゴールデンウィークにね
行って どこかに山の方に行ってね
池がありましてね 湖がありまして
結構釣れますよと そこでもう焼いてね
塩焼きにしてて あ それは最高よと
行こう 行こう 行こうとかね
そうすると殺生しない人が困る
困る 困る ゴールデンウィーク遊びに行きたいんですよ
山があるところで 湖があるところで
ボートに乗って楽しい
楽しく過ごしたいんですよ
しかし このプログラムの一つは釣りだからね
それに参加しなかったらどうしようなんか
だから悩むんですよ 功徳のレベルでは
しかし 命の尊厳を守るんだと言っちゃうと
すごいストレスはないんです
まあ行きますよ しかし
私は命の尊厳を守るんだからね
生きる権利 あなたにも魚にもありますからね
だから私は頼まないでください
あなた方は釣りやっていると
私はボートに乗って湖を三回ぐらい回りますと
余分な金私は払います
私の金 そこにストレスはないんです
俺は殺生しないからねと言っちゃうと
みんなに嫌われますね
なんだと イスはなんかねとかという風になっちゃうんです
しかし 禅になるとそれがないんです
なんかかっこいいんですね
私はね 命の尊厳を守るんだと
言うと 向こうに反対できません
それは巧みな行為 判断はいい
だからそういう風に不殺生会守る人であっても
これは功徳から善にすると結構ストレスなく大きな人間になっているんです
尊厳を守ることは自然な行為になる
慈しみを育てる 自分知らないうちに自分の心が慈しみにあふれているんです
自動的にわざわざ自我の瞑想してないんです
自我もう入ってくるんです
それで自我の錯覚が殺意を引き起こすのだと発見する
なんで殺意があるのかという
あ 自我ですよと 俺っていう気持ちだよと
これ錯覚やと成り立たないんだと
俺ではなくて 生命として見なくちゃいかんやと
私はではなくて 生命がこの生命がなんです
そうなってくると 自我の錯覚が発見する生命
だから私ではない この生命
その生命なんです ということは
みんな生命で見るべき
どれほど楽かと あの方は男性
この方は女性 あの方は弁護士
この方は医者とかね 考えちゃうと
ストレスたまりますよ
例えば皆様方 超エリートの方々だったら
何のエリートの人かけろね
私にここまで喋られる
私でこの空調でね 日本の政治家みんな来て座ったっても喋れますよ
何のことはない 天皇家の人々が来たってもね
私は生命同じだと だからそういう風に
この禅の方に行っちゃうと
すごい心が広いだけじゃなくて
ストレスひとかけらもなく
すごく自由を感じるんです
自我の錯覚が起こすのだと発見して
それをなくす 自我の錯覚をなくすということは
不殺生を完成する もう不殺生は完成しているんです
生命を殺さない 殺さないで
生命って無数にあるんだから
無限にいるんだから これは完成できません
しかし 禅になったらもう完成しているんです
自分には殺意が起こりません
それで終わり 終了 完成
不殺生を完成する 悟りに達する
それは悟りなんです これで勉強してください
嘘をつくなかれ どんな戒律でもいいんです
1本取っていったら この順番で完成するまで行くんです
だから我々は良いことをちょびちょびとね
良いことをするだけで人生を終えないでください
良いことをして それを善に入れ替えて完成してください
良いことは完成できません
善は完成できます はい
これから今日のテーマにじょろじょろ
そろそろ入ってみましょう
差別は悪行為です 非難合戦では一向に変わりません
世の中の人々は非難合戦ばっかりしているんだけどね
それでは世直しは起きません
相手に 1本の指を指すと
3本の指が自分を指しているんです
だからあまりに愚かな行為で
お前が悪というと  3本が自分を指しているんです
生命は平等という話 理論ではなくて
ただの話です 一切の生命に貪瞋痴があります
だから輪廻転生する生命というのです
一切の生命には貪瞋痴があります
だから生命は輪廻転生をする
生命との定義でもあります
貪瞋痴がある組織は生命なんです
だから貪瞋痴がない組織は生命じゃないんです
聖者なんです 聖者はサッターと言わないんです
特別仏教用語でアリアという言葉を使うんです
乗り越えた サッターというのは日本語では衆生有情と言うんですね
この衆生の情はこれかもしれませんだけど
本当は情の情を入れなくちゃいかんですね
だから情があるというのは
感情があるということは
貪瞋痴があるという意味なんです
貪瞋痴の強度によって区別が現れます
貪瞋痴はみんなに同じくはないんです
まあ貪瞋痴にも働ける
働くために肉体が必要だからね
あらゆる道具が必要だからね
そこで制限されます アリが怒っても人を殺すことできませんね
スズメバチが怒っても人を殺せませんね
10匹ぐらい群れで来なきゃ
しかし私が怒っちゃうと
スズメバチの巣を丸ごと焼くことできます
この差なんです 貪瞋痴を活動させる能力によって
貪瞋痴の機能性が強弱
いろいろランクがあります
それによって生命が一人一人違うんです
我々は人間だだからといっても
同じく貪瞋痴は動かせません
生命とは個の集まりですね
生命っていうのは個の集まりですね
日本国民といったら日本国人といったっても日本国ってないんですからね
日本国民なんですね 一人一人で
貪瞋痴で生きている生命が他の生命を指して批判することは愚かな行為です
指して批判することはできますけどね
だって蟻一匹 あんたいくら怒ったって
お前大したことできんでしょうとかね
あるいは蛇を見てね コブラを見て
体小さい割にね お前は瞬時に人を殺せるんだからとんでもないやつやと
だから俺は人間の怒りを使って
人間という肉体の怒りを使って殺してやるとかね
これとんでもない話 コブラも貪瞋痴で生きている
私も貪瞋痴で生きている
だから貪瞋痴の仲間だから
自分は自己観察するならば平等を理解します
この平等を理解するために自己観察するんです
自分の心を見てみるんです
そうすると欲があること
怒りがあること見えてくる
ああ 気持ち悪い そうじゃないんです
みんな同じなんです ただレベルの差があるだけで
無知であること あ 私に無知があって
あー情けないや 落ち込むぞ
これは とかね あー気持ち悪いじゃないんですよね
誰だって無知があるんだから
私は嫉妬深いんだからね
本当に暗くて情けない
それは正しい自己観察じゃないんです
私には嫉妬がある 嫉妬はちょっと強い
どんな生命にも嫉妬がある
強度には問題があるだけで
そうすると自己観察で落ち込みがなくなっちゃうんです
生命は平等やとわかるんです
これがこの個別があるのに平等ということなんです
差があるのに平等であると
差があって平等 差異があって平等
区別があって平等なんですよ
この西洋で言っているいい加減な平等じゃないんです
心の広い人間になります
それですごい心の広い人間になります
心の広い人間がね 他人に指を指しません
落ち着くんです 寛容的になるんです
ああ そういうことかと
自分の子供でも万引きして捕まったならばね
興奮しちゃって意識がなくなったりとかね
ないんです そういうことか
そこ心の中が見えてくるんですね
そういうそういう条件で怒りがあって
大体子供万引きするのは欲があるから
金が欲しいからじゃないでしょうね
それは大人の連中なんですね
二十歳ぐらいに十八ぐらいになっちゃって
勉強もできなくて 遊びだけで遊ぶ金がなくて
それは強盗なんですけど
もう普通の子供っていうのは
物を欲しがってやっているわけじゃなくて
別な何かあるんですね
心の中 社会に対して 親に対して
学校に対して なんか暴動を起こしてやりたいと
だから子供だから これで自分が破壊するっていうことだけは理解しないんですね
学校に迷惑をかけてやるぞと
それ 学校にいじめられているんですね
で 学校に目を攻撃したいんです
それで万引きしてわざと捕まっちゃう
学校はそれはごまかしちゃって
なんかその人のせいにしちゃいます
結局 子供の人生がそれで壊れちゃうんですね
だから心広いだったらね
親にそれはわかるんですね
そうすると解決策は見えてくる
人を非難しないで 今度は何かそういうことがあったらね
まあ言ってくださいと
私はあなたの味方だと
で 私に言いたくないんだったらと
他のそれなりの信頼できる年上の人に頼んでおく
じゃあ このおじいさんと仲良くしてください
あるいは学校のこの先生がいいでしょ
あなたの気に入りでしょ
じゃあこの先生に問題あったら何でもかんでも言ってという風に
この解決策も見えてくるんですね
だからこの平等理解しなきゃ
この世の中の問題は解決しません
世直しをやめて 他の役に立つように生きる
世直しは悪行為です ありえないでしょうに
ありえないことをやるんだったらバカもいいところでしょうに
可能なことをやるんですよ
絶対不可能なことをやるならば
相当頭がおかしいんじゃなくて
脳みそないんです もう肉だけ細胞だけあってスイッチオフなんですね
だから功徳の説明で説明してたでしょうに
完成できない いくらやってもまだやるとやるべきところは残っている
まだテレサさんもね やっぱりいくらやってもまだある
まだやらなくちゃいけない
でも自分が死ぬ そろそろ
そういうことですね だから世直しはありえない
成り立たない 不可能 それじゃなくて
あんた人の役に立つに生きてみてください
みんなそれに実行すれば
人類が人に役に立つことはけしからんというバカがいる
いないでしょうに いないんだったら実行すればどうですかね
人に役に立つこと どんな状況でも言ってるでしょう
どんな状況の話を聞いたって
人に役に立つことはどう思おうと
それは素晴らしいことと言うんですよ
だったらやれば 世直し見えない
私は 世直しは自我で行う悪行為です
世直しは自我 あまりにも自我エゴ
それは悪行為です ものすごい悪行為です
パーパなんです 不戦じゃないんです
個人攻撃をやめて真理事実を語る
それでこの人に教えるとこなんですけど
いきなり飛んじゃったんだけど
私たちが誰かの生き方の間違いを見えてくる
そうするとお前が悪いって
あれやめてください バカがすぐそう言うんです
んです ちょっと真理知ってる人にとっては
お前私なんか存在しない生命なんですね
生命が理解乏しい場合はやってはいけないことをする
だからそういうことをしたらどんな結果になると思う？これやりやり続けていいと思う？と相手に聞けば
そう思わないんだったら
なんでやったのですか？とかね
いろいろ理由を言うでしょ
まあいいわ それで終わったことだから
今日から真面目にやりましょう
それだけ やったことはまあいいや
終わったことだから それを忘れて
今日から立派に立派にやりましょうね
そうすると説教された人はすごい超気分がいいんです
こんな優しい人にはもっと信頼してほしいって聞いて頑張るんです
それが世の世の流しのやり方なんです
宗教信仰主義などの先入観をやめて
客観的な事実を語る みんなすぐ宗教を入れちゃうんですね
こんなことは神様が禁止しているでしょうとかね
それで相手が俺は神は信じていませんと言ったら終わりでしょう
話は あるいは日本でもいますよ
もう人を殺しちゃって
いや 私に神のなんとかありましたと
告げがあったと 人を殺しなさいと
だからそういう精神病気は使わない
人に道徳道を教える場合は
決して宗教を使ってはいけないし
信仰を使ってはいけないし
文化も使ってはいけない
例えば日本文化ではそんなことはやりませんと言ったら
相手がね あのね 日本文化は毎年変わるでしょうと
100年前の文化と今の文化は同じですか？と
昔日本の文化では正月やっちゃうし
お盆やっちゃうし 今日本の文化はハロウィンやるし
派手になる だから文化っていうのは変わるもんなんですね
だからそういうものを使って人を育てることはできません
我々その間違いをよくやりますね
なぜならば 仏教でいうこの善と不善
罪と功徳っていうのは
すべて生命に共通するものなんです
ある宗教の教えじゃないんです
ある哲学者の教えじゃないんです
だからそれを教えれば
人間に否定することは不可能です
他人に語る前に自分で実行して体験する
本を読みながら なんじこれこれやるなかれといっても
そういうのは万歳でいいんです
なんじこれやるなかれと言う前に
自分がやってみて 体験して理解して
その経験で喋ればいいでしょうに
ブッダの言葉はすっかり言葉遣いを学べば
その方法を理解できます
人に人の過ちを直す場合は
ブッダの言葉遣いを学んでください
あれは世界にある正しい完璧な言葉遣いなんです
ビシッと言うんだけど
個人攻撃されてないんです
尊厳は害してないんです
お釈迦様は一度たりとも難辞折衝するなかれとは言わないんです
言ってない いくら調べても
この出家に語られている戒律項目はそういう風にあるだけで
その時でももうもう極力避けてますね
指令することは 指令すると人権侵害侵害なんです
お釈迦様は言うのは 自分の幸福を目指すならば
殺生をやめた方がいい
あるいは逆に自分の幸福を目指す利己な人なら出場しませんよ
お前殺生するなかれと言わないんです
あの言葉遣いですから
誰だってお釈迦様に逆らうことはできませんでした
ブッダに会って喋ったら
もう 10 分 5 分喋って帰るともう善人になっていくんです
これ他宗教間違っちゃってね
お釈迦様は丸く使ってるんだと
あれは丸くじゃないんです
正せるのは自分と関係がある
自分の影響力が伝わる人々のみです
我々には世直しできません
私たちの話を聞くのは
私に関係ある人々だけなんです
この説法でも こちらに来た皆様にしか聞こえないんです
あるいは自分の影響力が伝わる人
その人だったら話を聞くだから
そんな程度で 我々の能力っていうのはいつでも有限であることを理解しなくちゃいけないんです
だから 自分にある限られた範囲で人を人に道を教えましょう
世直しやらまあね もう非難合戦やらね
辛くの世界やとかね もうもう嫌だ
この世界はとかね そんなに精神的に病気になる必要はないんです
自分の子供が間違っていることがあると
それを直してあげる 隣の家の子供たちには言わない方がいいでしょうね
自分の子供に だって向こうもやってる以上に
それは構いませんよ 君たちがいい人間になってほしい
世間の悪と向き合うということ
私は正しい 私は善人だという錯覚
傲慢 自我出張 悪の根源で
それが悪の根源なんで
で 悩んでいる人にとっては問題です
この世間が悪で だってみんな貪瞋痴だから
しかし 自分が 正しいと
という自己出張の人にとっては
どうしようかと 悪と向き合うことが難しくなるんです
で なきゃ別にどうってことないんです
だって私は日本にいるんだから
日本のテーラワーダ仏教の信者さんがいないでしょうに
いるんだけど スリランカ人誰一人私しゃべれません
私は悪人だと思っているんです
私にとってはネタ一つあるだけで終わっちゃったんです
日本人だけですからね
私の付き合いは 日本人もみんな仏教というわけじゃないし
みんな私みたいにいろいろドクドクするわけじゃないし
別に私はそれ 1度たりとも問題になったことはないんです
みんな貪瞋痴があるから生命なのだと知っている人に
何の問題も起きません
だから今日言いたいのは
世間の悪と向き合うということは課題じゃないんです
そんなのは問題にもならない
単純に生命は誰々貪瞋痴やと
私も貪瞋痴で生きているんだと
それでこの問題消えちゃうんで
これはたとえにしたんです
一匹の魚が他の魚たちに泳ぎ方を非難するようなものですよ
魚っていうのは泳ぎ方違いますよ
種類によって だから一匹の魚
なんでお前の泳ぐ方泳ぎ方は間違ってるぞと
例えばシャチのシャチの泳ぎ方あるんですね
シャチがイワシにね 君って泳ぎ方下手ですねとかね
だからみんな食ってやるぞって
なんかバカバカらしい話ですよ
自分は自分の影響を受けないなら
自分は なんか書き方間違ってる
変えますか？ ちょっとちょっと
どうやってどこで間違ったかわからなくなっちゃった
人はね 人は自分の影響を受けないならば
はい わかります いいです
いいです もう私の頭がこんがらがっちゃって
パーリ語で書いた方がよかったね
で 例えば世の中みんな悪い
周りも家族も友達も 会社の仲間もみんな
もうちょいいい加減にしろよという
自分が世直ししたいんですね
奥さんが旦那さんを直したい
だから腹が立っている
言って言っても聞いてくれない
会社の仲間を直したい
でも聞いてくれない 自分の子供の間違いを直して聞いてくれない
で どうする？それで自分が自己破壊する
バカバカらしいんです
会社の仲間みんなの性格が悪くたってもいいんです
直す必要ないんです 直せるならば直せますけど
直せないでしょ だったらあるブッダの戒めがあるんです
他は悪行為をする だからこそ私は悪行為をやめると
これは日常経典にも入っているサーリプッタのポイントなんです
これで全て解決です 人は怒るわ
足引っ張るわ 落とし穴作るわ
ああ まあ情けないと だからこそ私はそういうことをやめると
旦那さんが奥さんに言うことを全く聞けない場合はいいよ
私はしっかりした人間になる
それでこの問題は解決するんです
で ここでお釈迦様が世は悪であることを見事に使うんです
自己完成のために お釈迦様は使ってないんだけど
私たちにその方便を教えているんです
世は悪に満たしている
いいよ それで だから君は悪行為しないでくださいと
だからこそやる気があるでしょう
やる気が出るでしょうにと
俗っぽい日本語で言えば
お前みたいな人間には絶対なりませんと
そういった場合は その人を直す気がないでしょ
私はお前みたいな人間には絶対なりません
だから結局その人の悪い性格が自分を直すために助かったんです
それからまた世直しのやり方は対話と理解なんですね
説教は効き目がありません
人の意見も素直に聞いて理解しつつ
客観的に事実を語る対話形式が皆に有効的です
私たちの悪いところは対話しない
一方的に喋る 私が今喋っているような感じで
私もそれなりに頑張ってますよ
いろいろくだらんことを言ったりして
皆様は頭の中だけでも一緒に対話しましょうという感じで
相手が理解して納得いくように努力しないといけない
対話してどう思う どう思う
そういうことはなるほど
そういうふうに考えられますねとかね
でもちょっと考えにちょっと間違いがあるんじゃない
こういうところ こうなったらどうとかね
そうやってお互い話し合って話し合って合意に達するんですよ
それが人を育てる方法なんです
自分が上に立って人を育てるんじゃないんです
人に指令してはいけません
互い話し合って合意に達する
だからコンプロマイズなんですね
これはもうくだらないバカな人間にできることじゃないんですよ
結構自分ができてないと
だから人は成長すればするほど相手のことを理解する
相手に説教しない いつでも相手と合意に達するんです
人の能力はバラバラなので
他に他を諭す能力がなければ
自分自身を戒めることにしましょう
だからで すべての生命に私が言ったこの手段は使えないかも
対話形式で話し合って
相手のことはものすごく理解して
互い議論して合意に達するということは
ものすごく落ち着いていないとできないんです
いきなりあ これおかしいでしょと言っちゃうんですよ
すぐ判断しちゃう これやめなくちゃいかん
これ結構能力がいるんですよ
判断には達しません 話し合う
話し合う 話し合う 最終的に自動的に合意に達する
これできないならばどうしましょうか
できなくてもいいんですよ
別に自分を直すことに頑張れば
自分自身を戒めることにしましょう
それだけ あなたに言っても
相手に言っても言っても聞いてくれない
それでわかった 私はね
あんたみたいな人間に絶対なりません
はい さようならと それで話終わりでしょう
自分で頑張る それが他人の役に立ちます
自分を戒めることが他人の役に立ちます
悪は生命の本能です 悪は犯しやすい
善は難しい 善行為する人は自分の本能と闘っているんです
皆様も時々こんなことできない
恥ずかしいとか言ってるでしょ
あれ 本能闘っているんです
体が弱い人は電車に乗っても恥ずかしいと言うと目を閉じているんだ
寝るんです やっぱりちょっと本能と戦わなくちゃいかんですよ
わずかな善行為するためにも
成功する度合いによって人格が向上します
例えば わずかな功徳を行うためにも
わずかな善行為するためにも
自分の本能と戦うんです
だから戦って成功したら勝ったんです
また戦況するとまた勝ったんです
煩悩と 煩悩に勝ったということは人格向上したんです
なぜならば 煩悩とは貪瞋痴なんです
悪なんです 皆がやっていることをやる人の人生はそのままです
みんなやっているんだからやりましょうというのはとんでもない話なんです
みんなやってるからやるって言ったら
みんな悟っている みんな理性人
みんなすごい頭がいい人間
大衆は逆でしょ 大衆というのは簡単に騙される
感情で動く 本屋は漫画読む人々でしょうに
ですから みんなやってるから私もやりますっていうのは情けない
勇気を出して前に進まなくてはいけません
みんなやるかやらないかどうでもいいんです
良いことをやる 理性のある善人の指導を受けますが
世間の影響は受けないんです
これは仏教のスタンスなんです
理性のある善人がいるならば
その影響を受けます 世間の話には乗りません
利己主義ではありません
これは利己主義じゃない
どうでも自分が勇気を出して良い人間になりますと言ったら
自分だけでしょうにと
それは間違いなんです
そんな話じゃないんです
この善悪を知らない人が
利他自己とかそういう考えを作ったんです
あれはあの人々はもともと善悪を知らないんです
キリスト教に至っても
イエス様が受難しましたと
我々のために すごい利他行ですね
話おかしいでしょ イエスと神が同じだから
お前たちの自作自演でしょうにと
自己観察は自己戒めは利己主義ではありません
一切の生命に共通する命の衝動を発見するからです
だから自分を観察すると
自分がすべての生命に共通する衝動を発見するんです
貪瞋痴の働きを発見するんです
無知を発見するんです
我々は頭ではなく感情で生きている生き物だと発見するんです
それがすごいことなんです
心霊を発見するんです
心霊を発見することは
自利利他を超えています
こんな区別できません
そんな壁がないんです
自利利他超えています
だから自己観察しましょう
科学者は一人勝手に研究して何かを発見したら
それは皆の役に立つでしょう
科学者は自分一人勝手で楽しくてね
研究室で何 10年も閉じ込めて困っ込めてね
研究して何かちょっぴりちっぽけなちっぽけなことを発見するんですね
でも発見したらみんなの財産になるんです
みんなの役に立ちますでしょ
だから一人の人間が自分観察することは
あの科学者のやり方と同じなんです
人類の役に立つんです
他を慈しむ人は自分を慈しむ
自分を慈しむ人は他を慈しむ
だからこれは相互的で
自利利他と区別できません
真理を発見する人は皆の役に立つのです
だから一人の人間が真理を発見すると
それがみんなの役に立ちます
お釈迦様がシッダールタ王子で家を出て
宮殿を出て 王家を捨てて一人で修行したんです
一人で悟ったんです それで人類が助かっているんです
両目とも見えない生命の中で
片目が見える人は役に立ちます
だから能力一人だけあるんですね
でも役に立ちます だから一人の人間が自己観察すると
それは自己観察していない人の役に立ちます
仏道は両目を見えるようにするんです
片目じゃないんです はい
これで話終わりです どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
今日はちょっと早めに終わったので
30分以上ですね  3時47分ですので
4時半までですね  45分ぐらいですね
けどトイレ空気もとれなかったら台風も来るしね
まあまあいいか 早く帰りたいと思ってるでしょ
台風なので早く帰りたい方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんが
もしどうしても質問したいという方がいらっしゃいましたら
はい じゃあ  ありがとうございました
一つ 臓器の提供について質問させていただきたいと思ってます
日頃 保険証の裏にも臓器提供しますかって丸を付けるとこあるんですけど
日頃迷ってます しかし
今日ちょっと先生のお話から
業によってその寿命が決まってるって今先生からありましたので
あ そしたらもう寿命が決まってるんだったら
臓器は提供しない 残しておいた方がいいかなと思ったり
まだ自分の体を人に差し上げることを惜しんでいるのかなと思ったりして迷っておりますので
先生教えてください  そこまで迷うで
この肉体に対する愛着で肉体が腐っていくでしょうに
差し上げていいんですね
当たり前でしょうに 別にこんな悩むことじゃないでしょうね
でもありがとうございました
そう言われたら丸をつけます
他に質問あれば挙手していただきましたら
マイクロ持ちますが あ
はい  すみません  1週間ぐらい前に母が亡くなったばかりで
やっぱり思い出すといないっていうことがすごい寂しくて悲しくなっちゃうんですけど
どうすれば  いいまあまあ
それはだいたいね まあ感情ですからね
まあそのうちなくなると思いますね
あまり無理をする必要もないしね
うん それだけですね もう余計なことを言うならばね
あまりにも悲しくなって落ち込むのは親孝行していない連中なんですね
十分親孝行していたならば
何のことなく楽しいんですね
親が亡くなったんだけど
私は絶対やったよとかね
まあそれでもね まあ人が亡くなることは
親でなくてもね 一般人にとってはまあ悲しいことですから
まあそれはまあそのうち消えるもんだからね
ちょっと放っておけばいいんです
あまり思い出す必要ない
思い出すというのは病気ですね
それだけはやめてください
はい 以上です  他に質問あったらいらっしゃいますでしょうか
はい えーすいません この前小笠原という自然の豊かなところに行きまして
人間の方がマイノリティなんですけれども
そういうとこに行くと自分がすごい元気になるような気がしたのですが
これはなぜなのかというのがわからなかったんですけれども
ちょっと私も聞き取らなかった
えっと 小笠原諸島っていうんです
これ私の場合 耳に問題ありますから
あの 哲四郎さん言ってください
えっと 小笠原諸島という東京の南の方にある島に行ったそうです
そしたらそこ自然がめちゃくちゃ豊かなところで
人間の方が自然の他の生命のところでマイノリティである
そういうところにいたら
すごく自分が元気になったような感じがしたと
それはなぜなのかというのがちょっとわからなかったので
もし説明があればお願いします
まあマイノリティでしょ
人間がね だから本当のことをわかると落ち着きますよ
そんなに威張るんじゃないよとね
わかりますからね マイノリティの生き方はあまり残酷ですけどもね
人間が自然破壊してるでしょ
動物はやってないんですね
それはまあ本当のことだからね
大体どんなものにしたっても
本当のことを発見すると
なんか微妙に落ち着くんですよ
それっていうのは 知ることが人間にとってはすごくありがたいことなんです
仏教は知る世界で貫いて進むんだからね
知ることは智慧まで発展させますからね
何か知ったら楽しいんですね
そこで喜びが生まれてくるんです
そこで今まで今まで知らなかったという気持ちになってくると
ものすごく楽しくなるんですね
だからまあ 知ること すごい人間にとっては幸福なんですね
そういう法則です はい
以上です  はい 他にいらっしゃいますでしょうか
はい このはい  スマナサーラ長老はどうして私が人間なんですか？ 聞こえなかった
スマナサーラ長老や私はどうして人間なんですか？ それは私も知らないんですね
だから私たちはね この生命の心にね
エネルギーがあるんですよ
業というこのエネルギーってお金で思ってください
お金だと このお金がどれぐらいあるということで
何が買えるかと決めるんですね
そういうわけで 我々の業が人間という形を買うことができたんです
業がそれほど強くない場合は
犬という命を買ったり
猫という命を買ったりする
そうすると犬にできることは限りますね
猫にできることは しかし
猫にできることは犬にできない
人間になったら人間にできることも限っています
我々にとっては足があるんだけど
犬ほど走れませんね だから
そういう風にいろんな差が生まれるんです
我々は人間になっているのは
人間というこの肉体を作れるぐらいの業があったからなんです
だから これを生かしてね
チャンスですよ 我々は勉強できる
犬にはできない 我々は嘘を言わないでいることはできる
犬にできない そうやって我々には良い人間になることはできる
人を助けることはできる
そういうことで 犬猫たちに他の生命体にできないことをいっぱいやるんですね
我々はそれをうまくうまく使わなくちゃいけないんです
はい 以上です  はい まだ少し時間ございますけど
よろしいでしょうか  はい
一番後ろの席  今日もお話をありがとうございました
私はドイツ出身の方から質問を受けたんですけれど
仏教徒の方はなぜ托鉢をするのですか？という質問を受けまして
自分で野菜などを育てて
自分でそれを食べるっていうことをした方がいいというか
それじゃダメなのですか？という質問に対して
自分がうまく答えることができなかったんですけれども
はい 西洋的な考え方を持った方に托鉢っていうことを理解してもらうには
どういうふうに説明をすればいいのかどうか教えていただきたいです
至って簡単です 仏教徒は托鉢しません
そこであの人が勘違いしているんです
出家だけなんです 出家は托鉢です
在家の人は托鉢しないで
これ乞食と言うんですね
だから在家でありながら乞食をするならば
その人は人生失敗しているんです
出家はすべて捨てて 自分で決めてものを持たない世界に入っているんです
だから出家が聖なる道である托鉢しているんです
それは一つの間違いのポイント
だから Why Buddhism do in Begging と言ったら
ブッディストはそれやってないんです
仏教徒はちゃんと商売やってます
ちゃんと会社経営しています
で それから我々が托鉢することは
この精密世界 なぜならば
命が 1 日生きるということは
他の生命に迷惑をかけることです
他の生命に迷惑をかけないで生きていられません
そこで生命は 2 種類です
普通生きている生命と植物も
だから肉魚食べなくて
我々はキャベツを食べなくちゃいけない
石は食べられませんね
だから水以外栄養になるものは何か他の生命の形をとって入らないといけないという根源的な悪行為があるんですよ
そこで完全に禅になるということは
在家では無理なんです
それで出家は悟ればいいんだけど
まあそこまで完全に迷惑をかけない生き方をしましょうと
完全に迷惑をかけない生き方をしましょう
そういうことで 畑耕しちゃうとたくさん生命を死ぬんです
育てたジャガイモを取っちゃうと
ジャガイモの命がそれでなくなるんです
それから 俺が食べたいという欲がなければ
だからそれは汚れた道になるんですね
出家がそうではなく 托鉢に行っちゃうと
残った料理 生ものはいただかない
だからジャガイモの 1袋くれたら
それは断るべき 茹でたまま茹でたジャガイモもらったらありがとうございますといただくんです
だから茹でたジャガイモ
焼いた魚が自然に消えるだけであって
再生一切不可能なんです
だからそのエネルギーをいただいているんです
誰にも迷惑をかけないで
植物にすら しかし それが在家には無理
不可能ですから 在家にそんなことは言ってないんです
これは出家という組織だけ
で 我々はこの理想的理想に近寄ろうと出家がやっているだけなんですね
だから托鉢に出る場合は
もう何か人が食べて残ったものをくれれば
それは十分です そちらの良し悪しは聞きません
スーパーで買った生魚
生のそれはあまり受けてはいけません
キャベツ一つ これはちょっとごめんと
しかし キャベツ千切りしたキャベツを入れたらありがとうございますと
それで在家の方々に この聖なる道を歩む人々を協力するという
聖者の命を 聖者の道の人 の命を助けてあげるというすごい功徳が積むんです
だから日常で畑やって
田んぼ作ってやっている罪がかなり削減限定されます
リデュースね 下がっていくんです
だから托鉢することで
お教えの人々に功徳を積むチャンスをあげてあげているんです
そこで乞食にものをあげたってもいいんだけど
乞食がものをそれ食べて何する？お金もらったら
もう私は日本で昔よく見たんだからね
今あまりないんだけど
ホームレスの方々はもういろいろお金もらっちゃって
酒飲んでいるね ある日
北千住駅に私は朝早く 6時半なんですけど
大阪に行きたくて もう早く走っていったんですね
行ったらホームレスの二人の男性がベンチに座っていたんですね
人はいません そこらへん
私見たら あ どうもこんにちは
私はこんにちはと挨拶したんですね
そこで酒持っていたんで
どうぞどうぞそこ座って一杯飲みましょうと
優しい人ですけどね だから私は差別ないんだから
それ感じたでしょうね
それで じゃあどうぞどうぞ座って一緒に一杯飲んでくださいと
私は飲まないではなくて
すみません 今電車に遅れるんだから申し訳ない
ありがとうございますと言って行っちゃったんです
私 酒飲まないって自我張ってはないんで
その前は すみません あの
電車に乗らなくちゃだから申し訳ないと言ってさっさと行ったんですね
だから結局はそれはその人別にいいんだけど
だから私たちはそういう人々にいろいろ協力しちゃったけど
その人々は自分好きなように生活している
もしかするとスリやってるかもしれません
麻薬やってるかもしれない
いろいろ しかし 出家にご飯をあげたからといって
出家がそんなこと絶対やらないね
慈悲の実践したり 修行したり
だから自分をあげたものはものま
1万倍  1億倍実るんです
もしそのお坊さんがすごい仏教を勉強して
理解して すごい達人になったら
どれぐらい人々を助ける？だからはっきりお釈迦様がお布施するならば
出家比丘たちにしなさいと
お布施っていうのは托鉢でね
そういうことで 仏教的にこれ以上尊い行為はありません
はい うん  ありがとうございます
えーとですね 欲と怒りっていうのは
こう別個に現れることが多いと思うんですけれども
物惜しみの場合は欲と怒りのダブルパンチみたいな感じで思うんですけれどもね
その通りでしょうね しかし
この一瞬にも現れません
欲と怒りは正反対ですね
だから欲があると欲 怒りがあると欲
物惜しみの場合は順番なんで
まず欲 それから物惜しみ
ダブルパンチなんですけど
やっぱりそれも順番で当たるんです
はい 以上です  それでは皆さん大丈夫ですか？はい
ありがとうございます
あの政治家とかですね
政治家とか政治活動っていうのは
仏教から見るとどのように見えるものなんでしょうか
世界の政治家がね まあ基本的に言えば
まあみんな悪行為ばっかりやってるんで
これは私の考えで でも
ノーベルとかいろんな国で若者が総理大臣になったりする場合がありますね
これはすごくいいことやと思いますしね
あの 仏教の理想的な政治家っていうのは菩薩なんですね
いわゆる自分の便利 自分の
の幸せ ちょっと置いておいて
自分の能力を管理能力
理解能力 たくさんの人々のために使おうではないかと
だったら政治家になるしかないと決めることが菩薩行為なんですね
いわゆる素晴らしい行為なんですね
だから 政治家が素直に人々の幸せと平和と守ってあげたいと思うならば
立派なすごい良い人なんです
尊敬に値する一般人の人なんですね
俺が権力者になりたいと思ったら
これはもう極悪行為なんですね
これで結構儲かってやりたいとか
例えばアジアの政治家とかね
インド スリランカとバングラデシュとかね
地獄の道なんですね だから私は生まれる
かなり前 生まれる前ではなくて
1950年代のある日なんである
ものすごい立派な神様の智慧の神様のようなお坊さんいたんです
我々同じ学派なんですけどね
私はすごい尊敬するお坊さんで
このお坊さんがもうもう一晩あったら本一冊書けるというね
お坊さんで そのお坊さんがちょっと歌一つ書いたんですね
その歌は信者の子みんな覚えているもので
君は地獄に行きたければ
1 日総理になりなさい
または 1週間住職か神社の神主になりなさいという歌なんです
それ書いたところで発表した頃で
あのお寺は政治家にやられちゃったんです
すごい抗議が来たんです
あの  1ヶ月間ぐらい食事もなくなったんです
だから悪徳政治家でしょうに
だからお坊さん悪口言ったんじゃないんです
政治家の道を教えただけ
住職やってる坊主たちの道を教えただけ
日本の神社ではなくて
向こうの神々の居る祈り場あるんだけど
金儲けばっかりやってる人だまってる
だからそれにあの尊い方が道を教えただけ
綺麗な歌で 子供にも暗記できる歌で
私も何でも忘れるんだけど
あの歌を覚えているんです
4 行の詩なんですけど
だからそれは余計な話で
政治家がね 自分の懐を肥やすことを考えちゃうと
極悪の道 やっぱり国民に安全な国を作り築きたい
経済的政治的な安定して豊かな国民を作りたい
みんな幸せにしてあげたいと
してあげたいと思って
自分の贅沢を置いておいて頑張るならば
これは菩薩行で天界に行く一方道なんですね
はい 以上です  はい 他の方よろしいでしょうか
はい  最近兄が亡くなりまして
その際に戒名だとかというのがありました
位牌だとか such ものを例えばというふうに言って作ったんですけど
仏教的にはそういうものって元々あったんでしょうか
私の話を聞くと 私はお釈迦様の直々の話を皆様に日本語にして
現代文化に合わせて言っているんですね
でも中身は入れ物が変わっても
中に入っているのは同じものなんです
その話から考えると そちらにも判断できると思いますね
仏教ではそういうのは成り立たないんですね
だから葬式っていうのは文化なんですね
戒名なんかはまず仏教的じゃありません
戒名は悪くないんです
戒名は生きている時もらってほしい
戒名というのは仏教徒になりましたという意味なんですよ
死んだ遺体が仏教徒にならんでしょうに
これから燃やすんだから
ただの物でしょう で 本当はこの戒名は悪くないんです
習慣的にちょっとそれ文化ですけど
まあ勝手に慚愧してね
勝手に五戒を守れば仏教なんですけどね
私たちは関係ないんです
でもそれでもちょっと社会的な
ちょっと立場作りたいと思うならば
戒名をもらっちゃえばいいんです
生前 日本のお寺ではね
生前戒名あげる習慣ありますよ
誰も使ってないんだけどね
で まあそういうことで
お寺と仲良くして 仏教と仲良くして
仏像をあゆんで それでお坊さんが私に戒名一つくださいと言ったら
すぐあげますよ 別に私の場合は全く何も取れません
どんな名前にしようかと困ることはあるかもしれませんだけどね
戒名ちょうだいと言ったらあげますよ
それはまあ 仏教徒だよという
ちょっとバッジもらったような感じですね
その程度の話ですよ お位牌でも何でも文化ですよ
文化を壊す必要ないんですね
文化はそのまま やればいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
だから日本人亡くなったら
まあお位牌やら戒名やらなんだらかんたらとかね
文化ですからやってください
ブッダの教えとは関係ないんですね
大丈夫です  はい  では最後に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニドゥンカバヤンパッタンチェニバヤソーカンパッタンチェニソーカホントサンデーティパニノ
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が観音でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
カーンティー パラマム タポーティ ティンカー
ニッバーナム パラマム ワダンティー ブッダ